new game and deform okay let's um try
Kings Indian type of setup and played
that for a while so now all the big okay
maybe you really want to go for the
other buck with Bishop g5 no just a
classical again this is by far the most
popular line so let's see Makka is
playing the the sharpest continuation
whoopsie one yeah the ideas are quick a
quick c5 alum play a very very crude set
up with it always always like this
really a really good idea Queenie h2h
five okay so see six if I take what is
he doing Bishop c4 not sure
Knight f6 okay take some b7 all right
but the next move I just returned to to
c8 not sure the problem is i want the
bishop on CH because I I need this as a
sacrifice piece on age three so it's
it's really terrible on b7 but ok I'm
returning to the aid next move now ok
but Queen age five losses sir this is a
thread ok he wants to protect this with
them brush up to g1 what if I go nite h5
now threatening Nagi three now and age
30 I plain rg3 I don't I don't think you
can take this this structure would be a
would be quite quite terrible allowing a
pawn to g3 but not g three years of
thread just playing some some something
like this I plane I g3 what is the big
idea ok let's say let's see ok maybe he
just wants to play a queen you want and
pick this up I mean it's possible so it
doesn't really yeah I think I could just
I can just I can just sec on age three
one line i did calculators Queenie one
Bishop age three takes rook h3 King g2
and then Queen to h5 threatening rook h2
and if he goes rook h 1 i've got 96 rook
h3 and then night f4 check this is the
key the night on e seven can go to F
form and this should be the the the
piece that that decides hopefully that's
the plan at least I hope it works out
because some I've got this attack that's
all nice but cause the Queen side is
crumbling and the bishop on g7 is just a
dead dead piece so I need to really go
from medium but it's it's a very viable
very a very valuable player okay so
let's that sacrifice yeah of course you
can play Queen g3 now I mean this is
some this is a possibility yeah I think
Queen g6 night g6 is an idea it takes h
39 f 4 and then h3 is really really
falling apart let's do this the night
must go to g4 I mean at wherefore I need
the pieces in the attack
yeah this is very dangerous yeah that's
the beauty of the Kings Indian sometimes
you have those those games where
everything for the air falls into place
and you just get a nice attack on the
king this is some just just winning I
think a tree just was just gone now and
I always have queen age 5 as the next
time attacking peace so take age 3 now
who on can also take with them with the
night gap at this really should be ok so
how to to strengthen this now you can
now throw Lee just own play rook age
five and then 27 and don't turn see a
direct knockout also rook age six strong
threatening group g six and maybe this
one king f2 I just have not aged three
so we cannot have cannot evacuate the
king yeah this was nice and this must be
over I mean root g six computers on
minus four it's just just too much um
yeah let's let's check this briefly I
mean curious to see how the how the
computer evaluates this with it ok so
you p went allowed this which is really
risky I mean this is clear
okay Bishop c8 yeah computer grease with
all that and now the computer yeah place
the very pedestrian Bishop d7 check and
8x b5 with an extra bone yeah this is
not in the Kings Indian spirit yeah here
just gifts gifts equal gives it as equal
but this can be a case where you need to
let it calculate longer i think that
black is good here would be it would be
surprising to to learn that white can
defend i mean here the computer wants to
play age four kings you want so what did
you play it took and this please
probably lose this out right yeah this
the slowest so computer wants to go king
here yeah what an attack well it takes
here and now he wants to go here and the
assessment is equal funny let's just
let's just do a quick count I mean it
what is this I've got six point is God
fine I've got to have sacrificed a
peaceful poor now hmm very curious aha
now the computer gives me a winning
advantage today you just need to let it
I was just trying to find it out myself
and now it gives me the good line look
here Quincy for and now Queen to d8 with
the intention to play age 50 K age 5 and
then g4 on that edge and Queen to g5 are
Queen to h4 mmm this is its main line
the manor of the computer I black wins
it's too much I mean the night on f4 is
such a brilliant piece we've got the
rook in there the Queen jumping into the
action this is too much flex winning
here
yeah this is a very cruel plan but it's
it sometimes really leads to a disaster
white yeah thanks for watching
entertaining game